so as we go into the New Year and some of you are gonna be like oh my god
my relationship is the one thing I'm gonna work on
I'm gonna make sure that we go to therapy and we get everything right
um hear me loud and hear me clear when I say
a lot of times uh
narcissist will use the therapy to fuck with you even worse
they know how to put on a mask and put on a show for the therapist
and then they'll get the therapist involved in kinda making you the problem
and you just feel even fucking crazier
so before you go jumping into some couples counselling and shit
trying to work on shit
start some individual therapy
make sure you got your shit unlocked
make sure you know who the fuck you are
what the fuck you got going on
do you know what I mean
before you go to some couples counselling
where Homeboy is gonna be on his best behaviour to begin with
playing up a show for the therapist who's meeting all of you for the first time
so they're making their impressions and they're gonna go along with this like
I mean I don't know
like you only see a therapist for 30
45 maybe 60 minutes a week
it's real easy to put on a show
and it's real easy for them to be pushing your buttons
leading up to those appointments
so that when you get there
you're a little bit on edge
and you're not able to think clearly
speak clearly and
and express yourself correctly
and they're nice and fucking cool
calm and collected
and they got that mask on tight
so before you start some couples counseling
cause you're gonna work on your relationship this year
work on yourself first
a building is made above of bricks
individual bricks that what
that's what makes the whole fucking building right
you are one brick in the building that is your relationship
so make sure that foundation is solid
and that foundation is you
make sure your salad don't get mine fucked in some bullshit and
and get this year off on some crazy shit
you wanna work on that relationship that starts with you
you are half of that relationship
get your shit straight
and then you could go to some couples counseling